the UN Secretary General is warning that
Sudan is falling apart a violent power
struggle between the Army and a para
military force is now in its third week
the latest foreign mediated ceasefire
due to expiring midnight local time on
Sunday has barely taken hold at least
528 people have been killed tens of
thousands have been forced to flee their
homes Heber Morgan's joining us now live
from cartoons we've only got a few hours
left before this so-called ceasefire
ends here but it doesn't seem to make
any difference on the streets of cartoon
well neither this ceasefire or the
previous ceasefire made a difference to
many civilians and many residents of the
capital Khartoum some were able to flee
to neighboring states or across borders
into neighboring countries but those who
remain in hartum especially in the
northern part of the capital and in the
city of interman in the late hours of
Saturday witnessed intense fighting with
artillery strikes and airstrikes
launched by both the Sudanese Army and
the rapid support forces now the
Sudanese Army was able to take control
of Hellfire bridge that is a bridge in
the northern part of the capital and was
able to push the rapid support forces
further south to shambad's bridge that
all lies in the northern part of the
capital but the fighting was so intense
that residents were warned to stay
indoors to avoid being caught in the
crossfire troops were deployed and many
people said that they were not able to
leave their homes to get basic
necessities or to try to make it out of
the capital and that's in the northern
part of the capital itself in the
southern Parts in the in the western
parts uh in the city of umdurman people
said that the artillery strikes and the
airstrikes launched by the Sudanese Army
and the rapid support forces continued
into the early hours of this morning so
as the the ceasefire comes to an end
fighting continues between the two sides
the rapid support forces and the
Sudanese Army I have as the the
ceasefire is coming to a close obviously
the window for diplomatic efforts is
going to be closing as well certainly I
would imagine the efforts are going to
be more intense are we hearing anything
at all about anything positive with
regard to that diplomacy
foreign
well it depends on who you're listening
to now the Sudanese Army four days ago
said that they agreed to that ceasefire
that is due to expire uh in the next few
hours and that they will be sending an
Envoy to the South Sudanese Capital Juba
to negotiate with an rsf Envoy and that
there will be no direct talks but then
the Army Chief General Abdel fattah
al-bruhan spoke to a U.S public
broadcaster on Friday and he said that
any negotiations with the rsf would be
to make sure that they're no longer part
of the army and no longer an institution
in the country or to make sure that it's
uh that they're completely destroyed so
it looks like while the negotiations or
why diplomacy is ongoing to try to get
the two sides to negotiating table both
sides or rather right now for the Army
they have one goal in mind to make sure
that the rsf does not does no longer
exist then you have the rapid support
forces they say that they will agree to
talks if there's a ceasefire in place
and on the ground the fighting continues
between the two sides Heather thank you
very much indeed that's Heaven Morgan
talking to us from cartoon
tens of thousands of people are trapped
in their homes without medicine water or
fuel in some parts of Khartoum brief
loves in the fighting aren't allowing
people to stock up on the things they
need Al Jazeera has been hearing from
some of them who are risking their lives
to look for desperately needed supplies
thank God the medicines are available
here I even found them at the same price
as they were before the fighting the
prices of medicines haven't increased
here
to be honest I was worried the medicine
wouldn't be available I have a patient
with kidney failure and we brought him
here for treatment I was worried they
wouldn't have the medicine but thank God
they had stock
honest to God we work in difficult
conditions we open the pharmacy despite
the sound of gunfire for the sake of
families and children our problem is how
to get stock and in the quantities we
need the factories in the battery region
were bombed we display all the medicines
we have and try to do our best for the
people
well thousands of Sudanese are leaving
everything behind to escape the fighting
authorities in Egypt say 14 000 Sudanese
Nationals have entered the country in
the past week Sudan itself is already
hosting more than a million refugees
most of them are from South Sudan but
many are now returning home the UN has
also registered about 14 000 returnees
it says as many as a hundred and twenty
five thousand people are on their way
the UN also says at least 20 000 people
have crossed into Chad they're joining
400 000 Sudanese refugees who were
already there we've got correspondence
monitoring the influx of refugees to
countries bordering Sudan Ahmad Idris
reports from the town of kofrun in Chad
this dry riverbed is what separates
Eastern Chad and the town of tendulter
in Western defore over there are homes
and businesses left behind by their
owners because of fear of attacks the
residents woke up one day to find the
military base in town completely
deserted and that has triggered an
exodus of people thousands of them
crossed this dry riverbed into the
village of kofrun in eastern Chad and
they're based there currently thousands
of them under living under harsh
conditions while they can watch across
the dry riverbed at their homes over
there simply because it's not safe for
them to go back to their homes at the
moment now the situation is such that
people are in need of shelter in need of
water in need of food items and they've
been living like that for days until
they arrival a few days ago by U.N
agencies and the world food program
delivered tons of Aid to distribute to
the uh people affected by the crisis and
the migration across the river now
the world food program budgeted 20 000
budgeted for 20 000 people are the food
they have in their stores to deal with
the needs of these individuals however
from all indications that number is
going to outgrow the estimation of the
world food program and currently the
organization as well as other donor
agencies are struggling to deal with the
influx of refugees
traveling from Sudan into the eastern
part of Chad now 30 kilometers from
where we are is a town of Janina where
that we recently witnessed some
incidents violence incidents were
soldiers on both sides were killed and
we are told that a lot of people are
trapped in there and they cannot come
this side because of the security
concerns they have rather they are
moving further Inland into Sudan they
feel safer much much safer going that
way a family a humanitarian organization
family that escaped from Janina and made
it to kofun and then later to adre told
Al Jazeera that they spent days
negotiating their access through a
distance of 500 meters in order to get
to this place and that's the situation
here in eastern at the moment Ahmed
Idris Al Jazeera
well as we mentioned a large number of
people are also trying to return to
South Sudan haramatasas in the capital
Juba
the International Organization for
migration says there are about 1.5
million people from South Sudan living
in Sudan some of them are refugees
others when they're looking for work
when the fighting started people like
anag Ding and her six children left
Khartoum and came here to South Sudan's
capital Juba a journey that took them
about two days by bus and they're now
staying with family friends who've taken
them in for as long as it takes a
knockding says the journey for her and
the children to get here was traumatic
my children heard gunfire and saw things
they should never see they are still
scared I am happy we got back to South
Sudan savely
you know
South Sudan has closed ties with its
neighbor Sudan remember this country
gained independence from Sudan in 2011.
many people still have friends and
family stuck in Sudan and they're
worried about what's happening over
there the same experience that Sudan
went is what I went through in our
crisis in South Sudan where we have
witnessed people have been killed people
have lost lives people have been
displaced and children and and elderly
people have suffered most so when I saw
the fighting in Sudan it worries me more
because I start wondering the pain that
the Sudanese people are going through
salvacare saltadan's president is
leading mediation efforts as part of the
regional group egad he's trying to get
officials from the Sudanese Army and the
paramilitary RSA face-to-face talks here
in the capital Juba government officials
say it's still a work in progress
well the U.N says more than 75 000
people have been forced out of their
homes by the fighting but they're still
in Sudan large-scale evacuations of
foreign Nationals are still going on a
group of South Africans are among the
latest to return home
I feel very very very relieved to be at
home after a
very a long long long stressful Journey
started on Monday up until today we are
still on the road trying to get home
goodwix was really nerve-wracking you're
uncertain you don't know what's
happening you travel on the roads you
don't know if you're gonna travel the
ritual next next destination because of
the different factions so you don't know
if but we made it safely